freddie freeman the reigning mvp in the
national league
up the middle of base hit here comes
lecroy around third he's chugging for
the plate
the throw not cut off and freddie
freeman with a two out single
has put atlanta in front he caught a
break with a throw from center field
that didn't go very far luke croy not a
fast runner freddy
hit this thing bullet up the middle a
mistake by rogers
up in the zone on that slider and we
talked the other day about freddy and
ozzie two of the best
on the team in runners in scoring
position and freddie breaks through with
the first big hit
madame duval bats with two on and two
out or 17
this year with two outs and runners in
scoring position right at the top of the
national league in rbi's
troy sets up up and in and duvall sends
one forward left center field that'll
get down the base hit
nicki is in here comes cooper duvall on
his way to second
and the marlins take the lead well
what is bad for adam duvall he continues
to produce in these situations time
and time again to beat him on an
elevated fastball one that's in the
strike zone has got to feel so good for
adam duvall
freight knew that he could get into
chase up at the top of the zone but how
high could he go
he knew that he could not go to his
breaking ball his go-to
pitch with two strikes let's see if
after the meeting they told him
establish your fastball and dansby can
jump all over one
graves have three hits and that one's
hooked down the left-field line first
pitch
ambush into the corner that'll score one
rc around third he is going to be held
up he
slides past the bag and has to dive back
rbi double for dansby and the braves
have tied the game and they've got
second and third now nobody out great
job it's just a first pitch hanging
change up
and he jumps all over this ball right
down the left field line
and another thing good job by wash here
holding up garcia
two no outs last thing you want to do is
let rogers out of a trap now you got
second and third and nobody out
keep the line moving two balls and a
strike
and high in the air deep toward left
duvall going back to the warning track
he's going to make the grab
and tagging and scoring will be arcia
and dansby tags up as well heredia with
a sacrifice fly
again any other park he's taking the
grand tour
but he'll settle for the braves leading
3-2 let's see what freeman can do he's
got
one of the braves rbi's a third inning
single
swing and a drive hammer deep right
center field
that one is long gone homers in
back-to-back games for
freddie freeman of the braves have
busted it open it's five to two
well these last three games are starting
to look like the team we saw
chip last year and offensively
continuing to add to that lead to just
absolutely crush bullpens and here's
jazz
struck out his last time over two
and this time lines one to right field
acuna junior going back
leaps in he can't get there it's off the
wall and then he crashes into the wall
and jazz is on his way to third
[Applause]
freddie freeman saying it's the knee an
awkward leap by acuna who mistimed his
jump chism comes all the way around to
score but that's secondary to the health
of ronald acuna jr full extension
it might have been the the right knee
i think yeah that's the right knee he's
grabbing the right knee
we've got some serious serious air what
an
effort from acuna right there's a
spectacular catch he sticks the kind of
the landing and i think it may have been
awkward
jarred the right knee you never want to
see something like this
absolutely not this is a young superstar
in this sport despite everything that's
going on
freeman albies most of the team out
there by that right field wall
heredia and the training staff going to
help him up
but as an outfielder your focus is on
the catch so much so that
you kind of put everything to the
sidelines you're not really worried
about how you're going to land or deal
with the circumstances
after the effort and i think that may be
exactly what happened with acuna here he
was just so locked in on trying to make
that catch that when he came down his
timing was off just a little bit really
didn't come down that clean
well cunha jr who was walking
i don't know 100 or so feet under uh on
his own power
he sat back down it looks like some
tears maybe as well i mean he seems to
be in immense pain
i think i'm not sure that uh
they have called for a cart to get him
off the field
and boy you hate to see this now he is
going to get helped onto the cart
and foul territory there's never
doubting the intensity and effort that
this young man
plays with that has never been disputed
it's only been appreciated he's done so
many great things
in his young career that have opened the
eyes
baseball fans around our country he's
that type of player
and i think even the play itself really
speaks for itself and what we've seen
from acuna who is
highly motivated at all times on a
baseball field you've heard me say it a
number of times over the years
if everybody played with the the level
of energy and passion that uh
that acuna plays with i think our game
would be a lot different
yeah it's a pretty pretty high level of
intensity that
he brings every day to the baseball
field
so the marlins patient four straight
hits have him loaded
the 2-2 he got him to chase it max
turned that ball over and that's a much
needed fourth strikeout base is loaded
two away
you made a great pitch here when you
needed to you got one more to get
so alfaro hits with three on
two outs and he got it
back he's given his team a chance
this braves club has overcome adversity
all year long can they overcome some
more in miami today
that will bring up jazz and solo home
running inside the park home run back in
the fifth inning
oh one pitch on the way that's in the
left field and it's a base hit sierra is
going to score easily
and now jazz makes it a one-run game
all right marlins fans here we go
another big at bat from jazz shooting
the hole to the left they continue to
give it to him
yeah the front door is open come on in
why not there's nobody home
sierra scores easily but more
importantly jazz represents the tying
run in your hottest hitter
maybe in baseball in the box a guy who
could slam the door
shut right now garrett cooper
and a fly ball hit towards center ender
going back
to the wall has just enough room
and the braves have won the game 5-4
is your final never in doubt
got it the whole time the braves win the
series
they're back at 500.